alright good afternoon everyone I'm
Rebecca Gilbert and I teach at the
University of Illinois here in town in
urbana-champaign and today I'm going to
talk about Mathematica for any size
class and the thing I want you guys to
walk away from today is the idea that no
matter what your classroom environment
is there's actually something from
Mathematica that you can use in your
class environment and this actually
comes from my experience over the last
few years at the U of I and I'm very
thankful for that experience so it's
begin with how did I first get
introduced to Mathematica in contrast to
many presenters in the education world
who talked about Mathematica I'm younger
than Mathematica so I was not even here
much less in urbana-champaign when
Stephen Wolfram and company you know
we're testing Mathematica out for the
first time instead my introduction new
Mathematica when I was at my college
years my alma mater Grove City College
in northwestern Pennsylvania fame had a
stew Mathematica assignments in calc 1 2
3 differential equations and theory of
Statistics one and two along with other
extraneous courses here and there but
the idea was I thought that was
completely normal undergraduate
experience and turns out it was not but
that experience was very beneficial
because in 2012 I was hired hired to
oversee the calculus in Mathematica the
CNM program at the University of
Illinois here in Champaign and actually
to oversee a lot of the transition that
was going to go on with that program so
in this position I've been doing a lot
of curriculum development and it is
through these experiences that I want to
talk about the fact that you can use
Mathematica whether you have a handful
of students or whether you have hundreds
of students you have to make some
choices into what you will keep and what
you won't be able to keep but the idea
is that you can still use some aspects
of Mathematica as you go and teach your
courses so for those who might not know
what is the calculus mathematical
program historically it set the
precedent for Mathematica to be
incorporated as the computer algebra
system of choice at the University of
Illinois it was started by three
professors dear you'll crash yo port
and Bill Davis a view of I and Ohio
State respectively Ohio State University
where were we okay was first piloted in
the spring of nineteen eighty nine at
the U of I and the ideas behind this
program were based on very strong views
of pedagogy that students should be
experiencing the math through the realm
of Mathematica and this class structure
was drastically different from anything
that you would see you know 25 years ago
and drastically different from many of
the courses if you go into university
today so how was it different how did
these classes look um the main
difference was that students spent a
majority of their class time in a
computer lab working through Mathematica
notebooks there were usually no
traditional lectures associated with
these classes the idea was to experience
the math personally through the
Mathematica files and so they
constructed an entire curriculum around
this idea and it had a sequence of
Mathematica notebooks and so each lesson
had approximately or on average it
usually had four parts to it the first
part was called the basics this would be
your preliminary textbook portion the
second part with the tutorials now that
we've learned some concepts let's
actually see it in some worked examples
let's apply it and see how we can use
this practically and then the third file
was what was called the give it a try
but really instructors were told to use
this to create the homework assignments
so this is where you would get the
questions for students to complete for
homework and these again all Mathematica
notebooks the fourth file that was
typically included with most of the
lessons what's called a literacy file
and all this was we're short questions
there were very conceptual minimal
computation just a quick check did
students pick up on the concepts we were
trying to get across in the overall
lesson and the materials that they
should have progressed through at this
point so they created these notebooks
and the goal would be to have the
students spend their class time working
through the notebooks and then
completing the homework files and those
were submitted electronically groups of
you know two to four students type of
thing and then personally graded and
returned to the students with feedback
they
did this from calculus one up through
calculus three differential equations
linear algebra and probability and
statistics this program ran for over two
decades at the U of I and it ran from in
many other schools around the nation
especially during the height of the
calculus reform movement and it's what
led to the creation of net math which is
the U of eyes online and distance
courses and so this is what brought the
creation of net mass in but as I noted I
was hired to kind of oversee this
program or rather oversee transitions
that the math department was going to be
making with this program two years ago
and so what I'm going to talk about now
are increasing orders of magnitude the
ways that you can use Mathematica
depending on the number of students and
the types of students that you have in
your class so here are some recent
developments and recent experiences that
I've had in terms of will go up with
first we'll start with on the individual
level with students what you can do when
you have class sizes of 30 to 60
students what you can do there and then
we're going to talk a little bit about
what we're doing this year at the U of I
when we're reaching 400 to 500 students
in a semester with Mathematica but then
at the end I kind of want to challenge
the idea that there has to be a cap on
the number of students you can reach and
I think that we have a lot of potential
as users of Mathematica to reach more
students than we are doing right now and
I'll talk about that at the end of this
so first what happens when you have
individual students um so actually this
is not quite no specific class that I
was asked to teach but I've had a few
individuals over the years requested to
honors projects with me and this
provides a great opportunity to really
let them explore mathematical on their
own terms so since it was a mathematica
base class I said okay we'll go ahead
and write some Mathematica demos and
write a paper and will constitute that
that will be your honors project because
that's going above and beyond the
standard requirement for a class and so
last fall I had two students who wanted
to do things in calc 1 and I said well
let's look at some root finding
techniques and so they were able to they
looked
I'm trying to think of the techniques
off the top of my head the Newton's
method the secant method and bisection
method they looked at and explored
different route finding techniques
created demonstrations in Mathematica to
visualize what was going on to compute
these root finding techniques and to
really understand at the basics what was
going on what are the kind of
conclusions that you can take from doing
one-on-one projects with students
overall these projects were pretty
positive i would say that the students
did a really excellent job with these
and the reason being when you look at
things and you take a step back at the
end of the semester is students took the
initiative to do these honors projects
and then beyond that they got to pick
which route finding techniques they
would talk about and so they were able
to pick and choose the ones that they
found interesting and when you have that
happening you have students showing a
greater interest in something they're
choosing to construct then if it's just
a typical required assignment so if you
happen to be able to have the
opportunity to do honors projects with
students having them create mathematical
demonstrations and working through and
having them learn how to do that is
actually a really good way to
incorporate Mathematica one on one but
obviously not all of our classes are
one-on-one we're not all tutoring when
we're teaching and so over the years
I've had the opportunity any opportunity
to teach 30 to 60 size student classes
and these sizes are actually most
comparable to the old calculus and
mathematica course sizes and so this one
is on the some level the most comparable
to what had happened in the calculus
Mathematica program so I did this with
calc 1 2 and differential equations and
depending on the class a course number
and course credit I would meet with the
students one to two days in a
traditional lecture format and then one
to two days in the computer lab and in
contrast to other institutions that have
attempted to incorporate you know
Mathematica or any of the competitors a
key factor was as the instructor I also
ran the labs so there was a very fluid
transition that you would not
be seeing in if you read about the
papers of other people who are trying to
incorporate technology in their classes
right now so what did I do um primarily
I did what I had been asked to do and
that was basically to capitalize on the
improvements to both Mathematica in the
last 25 years and in our users the
students familiarity with computers in
the last 25 years we can all probably
admit that there are students who are
much more comfortable with technology
out there than we are as the instructors
and so um at the request of the
department I wrote new assignments that
both you know took advantage of
mathematical improvements and students
improvements when it comes to being able
to use technology and so these new
assignments taught students how to use
Mathematica commands for themselves that
was really the primary goal of these new
assignments and as we see it was fairly
successful in some classes and how did
we do that how did we teach students to
basically take command of Mathematica
further own self first we gradually
introduce students to the commands in
the assignments and the commands
introduced an assignment were directly
relevant to the concepts for that lesson
so we aren't going to introduce the
integrate command when we're talking
about derivatives and you know we
introduced the limit command at the
beginning of the semester when it was
relevant so they were directly relevant
to the concepts of that lesson but we
didn't just throw it to them we built
from the basics and we first said here's
the anatomy of the command and here's a
quick example so if you want to compute
a limit here's what it will look like in
a generic sense and here's an example
and so we pop them through short
practical examples but in the homework
assignments that the students had to
work through they weren't just short
practical problems they were often long
and involved thought processes that had
to be going into some of the problems
and so we said when you don't know how
to do something with your command refer
to the documentation center so we
empowered them by turning to the
greatest resource out there is to
actually learn from learn for themselves
how
to continue to expand their
understanding of the commands in
Mathematica and all of their options
another feature that I included with
these new home works were that I wrote
problem kind of descriptions so I told
the students you know what commands they
could expect to use now some of them
were very creative and would include
commands that I didn't teach them but
they went into the Documentation Center
and found on their own you know we also
included what the students should learn
from answering the question and why we
actually had that problem in the overall
homework for pretty much every single
homework question and very similar to
how the calculus Mathematica courses had
been run we had homework submitted by
groups of two to four students and then
they were personally graded and returned
with feedback to the students but the
primary change here was that we've
really capitalized on the advances the
last 25 years and really updated the
material and made it a little bit more
modular which we'll get into later on as
the primary benefit so just some brief
examples of how we did this I went down
and I just tried to type from memory a
you know a sampling of the commands that
students learned this is in calc 1 over
the course of last fall and last spring
so those are some of the commands that
the students learned and there are
certainly ones that you might expect to
see so the plot command and some of the
options and then one you know the prime
pie that came up in a random problem but
it was still one that the students got
to use it was kind of fun I figured I'd
just put up here two or three
visualizations from calc two so of
course that I taught last spring here
we're looking at visualizing and
computing terms of a convergent sequence
so often we talk about the word
convergence and divergence and in very
abstract senses students don't get it
but in a very concrete picture students
can look at that and understand that
sequence is converging in this case to
the value of two and at least gut
reaction understand what we mean when
we're throwing around these mathematical
terms this is a personal favorite that
students liked it is a visualization of
the alternating series test or rather
just looking at an alternate
series so in blue you have the terms of
the series and then oh the orange color
blue and orange colors of the U of I the
orange represents the partial sums so
students can see that the changes in
partial sums corresponding to the actual
terms of the series and they could
gather this information about why the
are alternating series test in this case
worked and what it really meant for the
series to be converging and of course
calc 2 is not complete without a
visualization of our favorite Gabriel's
horn you know the the object that has
infinite volume but finite surface area
students are always amazed when they say
you mean I can I can fill it sorry
finite volume but infinite surface area
you can fill it with paint but you
cannot paint the surface area of this
object now what are some conclusions
from updating and creating new homework
assignments that students it in groups
the first conclusion is that students
actually had far greater of a personal
investment when I use these new homework
assignments then to the previous course
materials that I had at the U of I
because they realized that they were
able to solve problems on their own in
Mathematica we taught them how to use
the commands and by the end of the
semester I can tell you that absolutely
every single student could use the plot
command without even thinking about it
and probably many more but the idea is
when they realized that they were able
to personally solve their problems they
have a lot more of a personal investment
rather than just taking you know a page
of code they were able to put in a
personal interest into solving their
homework questions the second conclusion
is an interesting one but I think it's
similar to a lot of the other studies
that are being done right now these
homeworks actually help to differentiate
for me the diligent eager to learn
students from those who were less
motivated so I'm comparing calculus one
I taught it last fall and then I taught
it again in the spring and when I taught
in the fall the average course grade was
eighty-four percent the students in the
fall were very diligent they were
hardworking when they encountered gaps
in their previous learning they put in
the
for to improve on their mistakes and to
fill in those gaps from anything they
might have missed in high school the
students in the spring however one let's
point out some differences I was able to
revise a lot of the material from the
fall that fed into the spring material
so they should have had you know better
material I was also meeting with them
one more day a week than I had been in
the fall but at the end of the day their
course average was a sixty-nine percent
these students on average came in a lot
weaker and many of them did not put
forth that personal effort necessary to
improve over the semester all of the
students in the spring had seen calculus
one before all of them had failed
calculus one before some of them would
just skip midterms they didn't really
care too much to put forth that effort
to do well so what was the impact on
their end of the semester assessments
from the fall the students who worked
hard fifty percent of the students on
their course evaluations said that
Mathematica when they're asked what was
the most beneficial aspect of the course
fifty percent listed Mathematica in
these assignments that we did and you
know some of the quotes you can see
right there mathematica allowed me to
visualize many parts of math I didn't
understand before so for these
hard-working students fifty percent of
them listed Mathematica the most
beneficial aspect compare this to the
spring 21.4 percent said that
Mathematica was beneficial but 28.6
percent of the students said that
Mathematica was the one aspect of the
course that they would change so this
goes to show that for the students who
really want to are motivated and want to
learn mathematica especially the
visualization and being able to see
things um and have that quick
computation it was valued and
appreciated and it helped them for the
students however who didn't want to
personally push themselves it was not
viewed as favorably and it did not help
them as much so this was useful it was
beneficial but if you're a student at
the University of Illinois and a ver
student you don't get to go through a
class of 30 to 60 students the average
student at the University of Illinois
when they take calculus will go through
large lecture sections of calculus that
are going to be 200 to 250 students per
lecture section so the question that the
department wanted to ask this year is
can we still use Mathematica in the
large lectures and that question I
answered with yes to some extent we can
still use some aspects of Mathematica
with the large lecture classes so what
are we doing this year at the U of I
this fall we're working with two large
lecture sections of calc 1 and then in
the spring this upcoming spring we'll be
following up with two large lecture
sections of calculus two and these large
lecture sections I said 200 250 students
they'll meet two days a week with a
faculty member in the classroom and then
they'll break down into small ta lead
discussion sections 40 to 50 students
the other two days of the week and each
section when they meet with the graduate
TA and they in keeping with the
tradition of having the peer advisors we
kept to undergraduate assistance to go
into each of those discussion sections
and help the graduate student out but in
doing something on such a massive scale
we had to think and answer a lot of
questions and say what aspects of
mathematica can you scale up if you're
going to be doing a course of the old
this size and the conclusion we came to
is that you could not personally grade
group home works anymore it is not
feasible to do it on this scale but we
didn't want to lose what we saw from the
smaller classes that visual benefit and
the computational benefit we wanted to
keep that and so that's what we said
well let's go ahead and develop a bunch
of CDF demonstrations and the way we're
going to incorporate it is sometimes in
the classroom I definitely bring it into
the classroom but when they're doing
their active discussion worksheets with
the Graduate ta two days a week in their
small
we're going to have some of those
questions the ones that require them to
access a CDF and so what we've done is
normally the students would go to their
ta section and they would work in groups
of two to four on paper worksheets and
it was it's very the University of
Illinois is very excited to be doing a
lot of active discussion learning in
these sections and so we're keeping that
energy in these discussion sections but
now the paper worksheets about half of
the questions this semester are
directing students to CDF demos that
I've created and some of them that you
know it's helpful to visualize things
and other times they need it for
computation so one thing to note though
is that in using these CDF's students
are not going to be using Mathematica
commands or code anymore that is one
thing we had to let go of but the good
news is that these CDF's are providing
students with that prompt prompt
computation and concept visualization
which is certainly an improvement over
static textbook figures we can all agree
that the manipulate command is certainly
something that we can't live without now
at least I cannot live without in the
classroom so here are two examples i'm
going to show you a bad example and a
good example of how you can use a CDF in
class so first the bad example when
you're dealing with related rates you
sometimes get the angle of repose
question of if you're pouring corn out
onto the floor of a barn you know what's
the shape that it you know that it makes
and so we have this manipulate that kind
of shows the corn pile growing um it's a
good graphic but really it didn't do
anything for students it doesn't know
none of the students said they liked it
in fact some of them said they would
have just rather had you know a
two-dimensional sketch on their paper so
there really isn't any point to
including this as a demonstration what
I'm about to show you though is
something that students only halfway
through the semester have already said
is one of the best things they've seen
in this course and that is a
visualization of the mean value theorem
so I'm going to shrink the size
just a little bit so that we can see
this the entire thing but the mean value
theorem when you first present it in the
classroom students eyes glaze over and
that is because it's a bunch of bath
jargon and if they don't stop and think
about it they're really not going to
understand what you're talking about
it's just a bunch of symbols on the
paper so what we wanted to do was have a
graphical representation of the mean
value theorem and we told students
before they went to do that worksheet
that we want you to use the graphical to
make sense of the mathematical and other
times we'll give them a graph and say
use the math to explain what you see in
the graph so the mean value theorem says
that you know for any two points that
you pick on a continuous function
there's some point between them that has
the same instantaneous rate of change or
the slope of its tangent line is equal
to the slope of the secant line between
the other two points and so students
were able to play around pick any two
points a and B they wanted or even have
manipulate basically do an animation of
what's going on and students would sit
there for a few minutes but they all
came back the day after they did that
worksheet in one of the sections and
they said this helped they now
understand what the mean value theorem
is talking about because they had this
concrete visualization they were able to
use the graphical to make sense of the
mathematical and so this is what I would
say is a useful implementation of the
CDF in the classroom or in the
discussion sections the students got to
experience what it really means for the
mean value theorem visually to make
sense of what we say when we're out the
board so even though we're only halfway
through the semester I do have a few
conclusions based on the data we've been
collecting in the first conclusion not
even based on data all of these CDF's
maybe module ii incorporated into any
course i substitute taught for someone
yesterday who incorporates absolutely no
technology into his calc 1 section and I
still took a CDF in there of Riemann
sums and that's because students don't
really need to have
previous experience they just need to be
someone who's comfortable using a
computer screen and pretty much all of
our students are at this point um we did
have to trade students learning how to
personally use mathematica on this scale
but in exchange we're still having
students harness the power of
Mathematica without that steep learning
curve we're still getting all the
benefits and in fact we're extending the
benefits too in order of magnitude more
students than had previously been
reached the last conclusion though is
one that every teacher faces while these
concepts are beautifully demonstrated in
CDF's the CDF's themselves are unable to
for students to apply themselves and
this is again a similar concept to what
we saw in the conclusion from those 30
to 60 student classes you cannot force
students to apply themselves and this
can be problem ental for students are
detrimental for students on exams no
matter what size the class is but we are
collecting a lot of data on how this is
going this semester so probably in
another year we'll have more concrete
numbers to give for it but one thing I
wanted to conclude with is I don't think
that 400 or 500 is really an upper bound
I know it's a rather large class we're
going to have a large sample size to
work with but I don't think there's
actually an upper bound how many
students you can reach online classes
are here to stay there's not much
question about that the question is how
do we utilize them how are we what are
we going to incorporate with them many
studies have been done that show online
courses work best for self motivated
students these are the same students who
appreciated Mathematica in the smaller
scale classes so in some sense online
classes working best for motivated
students it'd be great to be tying more
Mathematica into that but like Harvard I
want us to question whether we need to
restrain ourselves to the word classroom
or course Harvard now considers online
learning activities and the idea of
modular built things by popular choice
when students need a reference they turn
to Paul's online notes or if they want a
video they turn to the Khan Academy
but right now they are not turning
routinely to the Wolfram demonstration
project which is really the strength
behind what a lot of educators could be
using and so I almost think that the way
Mathematica could be incorporated is not
so much thinking about course but
thinking about creating the 21st century
version of Paul's online notes or
creating the 21st century version of all
of these modular explanations of
calculus or differential equation topics
that have the CDF demonstrations or
anything else that mathematic is coming
out with that is completely beyond my
understanding right now in the cloud but
the idea is there aren't conclusions to
this yet we're the ones who will be
writing the conclusions and there's a
lot on the demonstrations project but we
need to make it what becomes the next
standard when students need to turn to a
concept and understand it better so
there is not an upper bound to how many
students we can reach the question is
whether we all put our resources towards
becoming the next leader in math
education thank you